[Musique]
en préambule effectivement on est sur
une nouvelle relation
commerçants
et
évidemment consommateurs je vais le dire
une fois pour toute et sera seule fois
on sait que c'est l'exercice le plus
difficile qu'existe le commerce en
milieu rural effectivement une relation
qui a changé avec une notion de
proximité de volonté
de relations humaines dans le lien
commerçants
et c'est là où il faut effectivement une
solution simple le préfet on a vu
disparaître on sait plus comment ça
fonctionne le fisac là où il faut faire
de la rénovation de commerce
l'accessibilité des commerces parce
qu'il ya 3 mars à la boulangerie et
qu'on dans kick in le boulanger à
trouver des solutions
il faut absolument
notre collègue maire de loiselet à
l'évoquer sur la création des grandes
surfaces au public on est des
commissions départementales
il faudrait que la les communes
concernées ou d'impact soit entendue
dans ces commissions départementales
quand il ya des ouvertures de commerces
qu'on convoque ou qu'on invite les
maires concernés pour savoir quelles
seraient les études d'impact de
l'ouverture de telle ou telle grande
surface et et qu'ils aient non seulement
droit à la parole mais effectivement
d'être entendus sur un certain nombre de
points
précis
les histoires de maison de services au
public dont on a parlé ce matin avec la
mise gros has est bien de les mettre là
où aussi on va apporter
afflux de clientèle éventuellement près
de l'épicerie près de la boulangerie
faut qu'on ait une vraie cohérence dans
ses aménagements ou s'arrêtent 2
le d'aménagement
et puis il ya un dernier sujet essentiel
j'ai regardé mon exemple de boulanger
parce qu'il me plaît bien si on veut
qu'ils aient des boulangers il faut
former des futurs boulangers c'est aussi
bête que ça on voit bien finalement un
trail de bon sens à mener et surtout pas
un truc trop jacobins